all right people the Internet is about
to crash and SJW heads are about to
explode this is our second live stream
of the day I've already put in two hours
of work people but we're back and I am
sitting here I can't believe it's a live
human being
Carl Benjamin aka Sargon of Akkad how
you doing man
ty it really really tired you just need
that the journey was long and stressful
but it's good to be here you flew across
the pond yeah yeah how did that go for
you it was fine
naturally at night the journey wasn't
uncomfortable it was just really long
yeah get up really early instead of
really late alright let's start with
with first things first I think a lot of
people although you do show your face
now okay it's pretty pretty frequently
and you do other shows and live streams
and all that stuff I don't think people
are really used to seeing the human you
know Carl they think of this the Sargon
fella are Carl and Sargon the same
person we're gonna leap right off the
top yeah I don't have a persona or
anything so I you know it's just Sal
Khan was my gamer handle yeah I always
used to use when I was playing video
games with my friends and it was just
you know I you know just used it to
register on whatever websites I was
using and I registered my YouTube
account about three years before I even
thought about posting a video yeah I
never reconsidered changing or anything
cuz I never thought anything was gonna
come of it if I thought that one day I'd
be sat here talking about things I
probably would have just used my name
right but I just never occurred to me
and now I'm here and now I'm stuck with
the labels it's too late you can't
change you you I like the name you know
I like the I like the historical figure
so it's fine it's just not what I
planned yes I didn't plan anything so
we've discussed a little bit you've been
on twice before once once you really
helped me out cuz we were in between
studios we do a little hangout thing
you're a good man and we've discussed
some classical liberal stuff and a bunch
of stuff that we're going to get into
but for people that have no idea who you
are why did you start making political
video
I was disturbed by the amount of
nonsense I saw from the regressive left
in the media it was um it was a lot less
then than it was now than it is now yeah
but even then this was like three
probably four years ago now where I was
just I was constantly just seeing this
nonsense and it wasn't just the
regressive left it was it was many
things but it would I was honestly just
at the point where I was thinking right
okay I can see what's happening I can
see why I'm not happy with it and I have
the choice to either do something or not
do something and my conscience just
wouldn't let me sleep I couldn't I
couldn't just do nothing
yeah and I don't I never wanted to do
any of this I know I don't I don't want
to be like a public figure I don't want
to have a media presence I don't want
any of that but it just I felt like I
had to you know I have to do something
and three years later now Here I am
yeah so we'll get to some of the stuff
that you were seeing that you didn't
like what we were political leanings
before all that I've always just
considered myself a liberal definitely
not the American version of what a
liberal is yeah in Britain you're
talking about sort of the sort of
Lockean thomas paine sort of liberal you
know you're not talking about the
progressives who come from a
fundamentally as far as far as I can
make out cuz I'm not even sure they're
that certain of their own beliefs mm-hmm
it seems to me they have a set of goals
in mind but don't really know how they
plan to achieve those goals through an
ideological framework and so when they
they come out and advocate advocate for
things like affirmative action you know
that is completely illiberal to advocate
for just an end equality because I mean
for a liberal to say that I want an
equality of outcome is the antithesis of
what liberalism is it's a causative
opportunity and from a quality of
opportunity you are going to see an
inequality of results and that's the
point because an equality of result
means that someone somewhere isn't
getting what they want they're being
artificially restricted by someone else
whoever setting the rules you should see
a natural diversity of thought opinion
and outcome when you are operating in a
liberal system so to ask fish they wait
it and
is well illiberal and i didn't like it
so when i was waking up out of the
progressive coma and I started just
tweeting a few little things that I
thought were wrong this is about about
three years ago I'd say suddenly the
internet started all at once talking to
Sargon talk to Sargon you were really
the first person that they said this is
the guy that's online talking about this
stuff and then you had me on your show
which you had a much bigger audience
than I did at the time it helped me get
some of my face so I so first off I
thank you for that but did you realize
that talking about basic classical
liberal John Locke you know on Liberty
Values was gonna be thought of as
somehow controversial or something in an
odd way it is in some bizarre sense
there's hmm how to put it I didn't think
it was gonna be controversial I I
honestly thought that I would I would
get a lot of positive responses from the
people who were doing these things
because I because they called themselves
liberals and so I was like well why are
you doing things that are going against
the core values of liberalism and it's I
mean at the time I wasn't even
particularly well read in liberalism I
didn't really know very much about it
but I knew I knew the sort of outcome of
liberalism and I knew the the principles
but I didn't know the intellectual
history of it and so I have to educate
myself on that obviously and I think
that what progressives really need to
ask themselves is do they want equality
of opportunity or do they want equality
of outcome because that is the the core
difference between liberalism and
progressivism and I think there are lots
of them think a lot of people I mean I
hear people saying I'm a liberal
progressive it's like what does that
mean you know and I think what the
problem is is they've got a certain set
of overlapping magisteria where they
want things like tolerance that's a
perfectly respectable thing in a liberal
ones tolerance but tolerance for a
liberal is the consequence of the
principles that they're operating under
whereas for progressives it's the goal
of their principle so they are quite
happy to say restrict someone's freedom
to apply for a job is is a really
classic one in order to achieve what
they consider to be a tolerant end
but that to me is not something I think
I mean for example the BBC at the moment
I ever and for anyone who doesn't know
is the state-run media corporation of
the Britain they and this is my my
taxpayer money goes to this my license
money goes to this they actively
discriminate against white people on in
in hiring for their jobs and it's not
not all the jobs obviously but they have
certain jobs where they will literally
say this is for and the term in Britain
is black and minority ethnic but it
basically means non-white for beam only
and it's like I'm sorry what on what
planet do you think it's acceptable to
say you know you're the wrong race to
apply for this job and things if it was
for a job say in front of the cameras or
something I maybe I could bend my
principles enough to say okay fine you
know I can accept that but I mean these
are what would be the purpose of that
just just to be clear so you'd want just
so that there would be some sense of
diversity on what you're actually seeing
yeah I mean I I I can tell you're not
you're not thrilled with that no I'm
yeah I I could at least accept it and
say well okay you know I I can
understand your reasoning and I'm not so
offended by both but this is for like a
researcher behind the scenes and it's
like no I'm sorry there's no reason in
in my political lexicon that you can
give that is acceptable i I don't find
that acceptable and so this is this is
the question do you want a course for
outcome do you want equality opportunity
and I want equality of opportunity in
not outcome yeah and the progress is on
the opposite so you obviously in this
ten minutes or so here have said nothing
racist or bigoted or anything like that
but there is a because of the way that
the progressives are using race there's
a racial connotation to all of this and
I what was it i think it was there was
there an article written about both of
us or something probably done something
there are many where somebody was
calling you a white nationalist airwaves
who promise there's something I wish I
could remember the specific instance of
it I and I remember pushing back on it
of course but but therein lies part of
the problem that that our education I
think for both of our countries is so
screwed up right now that when you say
these sort of very obvious things about
equality of opportunity vers outcome
which everyone should be on board if
truly care about equality people think
that somehow a racist country so this is
something I thought long and hard about
so for example when they say we want to
see we want to have a job that's open
only to say I'm just going to use the
term - I'm black but I mean non-whites
and white yeah though they're only open
to black people then you ask them okay
what's the rationale flag well black
people are disadvantaged they're often
very poor they come from difficult
families and say okay well why don't we
just open up to people who are
disadvantaged and poor that's something
we can qualify very easily mean we can
figure out who's poor by simply looking
at their paychecks and looking at their
mother you know with monthly income so
the issue is not actually the race the
issue is the financial situation of the
person so why discriminate against the
white people on the basis of their race
if the problem is that they're poor the
problem is another poor the problem is
that they're white and the other ones
are the problem you know and the the
favor in the progressive mind is to go
on to the people who are black purely
because the the perceived disadvantages
of I guess being black which to me
sounds like a racist thing to say which
mean I gladly yeah additionally yeah
exactly yeah i I don't look at a black
person think well you'll probably
disadvantage that's then I mean what I'm
advocating for I guess I maybe it's
because it's outside of the paradigm
because what I'm advocating for is a
racial you know it's it's not I don't
want their race to be a factor on which
they are judged and yet these people
can't seem to separate that from the
situation that we're talking about and
so if I'm saying look maybe you should
be judging people and maybe something
that is more controllable or maybe
something that is more relevant like I
mean financial situation is something
that is genuinely relevant and it
affects black people white people red
people who ever you know it's if that
becomes the category that you focus on
then you can help people without racial
prejudice being a factor in your own
decision-making and that's the thing but
every time you discriminate in favor of
someone on the basis of their race
you're also discriminates other people
against them
on the basis of the race yeah and that
to me is what racism is but isn't the
interesting piece of that is that I
think the people that that hold this
ideology they don't mind that kind
discrimination they think actually that
that discrimination they wouldn't call a
discrimination but they they think that
that discrimination is actually positive
because there's a certain set of them
that think that the white man or
whatever or the patriarchy and should be
punished right like this yeah this comes
down to the problem that the root
I think the root problem of most
ideologies and the sort of public
conception of them is the redefinition
of a certain term almost every ideology
if you look at them and you look at them
in detail they'll come down to a
redefinition of intent for example
freedom is one of these terms for
classical liberals that a lot of many
many classical liberals define freedom
like libertarians always define it as
freedom from mmm-hmm not freedom too but
the the way many classical liberals will
some at least will describe it as being
oh it's what you consider to be
something to be free from for example I
mean poverty can well be considered an
oppressive force you can you can measure
the oppression of poverty there are you
know many studies that show it decreases
your IQ decrease your lifespan all these
other and decreases various
opportunities again it puts you in a
lower class and when you go into a lower
class you you end up finding yourself
with inherent disadvantages just because
of your mannerisms and the way you speak
but you know I mean for example if you
see someone like Franchesca Ramsey I'm
sure a lot of people know who she from
MTV she's a very well-spoken yeah
incredibly well-read she's an
intelligent woman she's not lower-class
but if you take someone like you can
find almost anyone on lively for example
one of these old videos you see going
out right people brawling none of those
people will ever get a job on MTV and
it's not because they're black because
MTV's happy to have black people it's
because they're poor and they're lower
class so I come in where your question
was a half-caf well so so from so from
that though what are the what are the
basic liberal classical liberal beliefs
that you have like what do you think
sort of encompasses what the modern
classical liberal right K so these I'm
okay so one of the I mean I personally
won't see everyone treated
as equals I mean the for me of what I
interpret classical liberalism the the
core principles and that the ethos
behind it is to create a brotherhood of
man effectively a system of peers and
equals because it came out of time when
there was an aristocracy and it was that
the problem was the aristocracy
oppressing almost everyone else in
society and I think this is the reason
that I find the social justice warriors
so offensive because what they want to
do is turn their minority status into
power over you hmm
they want to turn themselves into a new
aristocracy where on the basis of the
fact that there aren't very many of them
and they have a distinguishing quality
between them then everyone else has to
obey their rules and I'm sorry that's
not acceptable to me what has to happen
is they have to obey the rules of my
Chapman majority and if they can't put
themselves in the rules of majority then
I'm sorry but we can't just remodel
society for the whims of a small group
of people because that creates an
aristocracy and I that fundamentally is
what classical liberalism is about in my
opinion so why did these ideas which are
hundreds of years old of classical
liberalism why did they get buried to
the point that when I started waking up
to this stuff that people were going out
you got to talk to Sargon because you
wanted tools on YouTube and not like why
wasn't there someone else like a
mainstream person that they could have
been like that this guy's been talking
about that forever instead they're
telling me to talk to you the kid I
don't know I I mean it could be that
it's the the water we swim in and so you
know fish in water probably doesn't have
a word for water you know that's
something principle yeah it could well
be that we are so subsumed in it we just
take it for granted and we don't really
realize the sort of creeping degradation
of it until suddenly we're looking at
racial quotas and racial discrimination
in public organizations and things like
this I mean I honestly I don't know why
it's ended up this way I don't know I
mean there are so many problems I think
that the I think the I imagine them many
of them stem from the quality of
University of the moment leaving the
STEM fields aside of course there there
seems to be a nascent socialist
revolution brewing on our universities
and that to me is highly disturbing in
the same way that an
mr. revolution is disturbing when it's
brewing in the mosques yeah you know
it's not all of them it's some of them
and it's indoctrinating enough of them
that it's becoming a real problem this
is why we see I mean hundreds of anti
far
no that's clad in black all from the
middle class all university educated all
absolutely terrible at fighting each
other and we see them in the streets and
they feel justified they think this is
all completely within their their rights
to do this and they think they're gonna
create a better world at the end of it
and the irony of it is you can't point
to a social assistants exist that's ever
work there's always an excuse why that
work that wasn't the real been is no it
wasn't the real one that wasn't their
own nobody do you think we're at a
particularly strange precipice in the
world right now where this battle
between all of this postmodern stuff and
cultural Marxism and SJW stuff versus
those of us that are really you know
somewhere in the middle trying to
explain what freedom is versus the
authoritarians on the right that because
of the internet because of globalization
that actually the whole system of the
world seems like it's it's in a
precarious place alone is that is that
alarmist I think that we've come back to
the cycle of history I mean if you look
if you look back hundred years ago we're
looking at the Russian Revolution it's
not it's not particularly different you
know and you've got the alt rights and
you've got the anti fire crew fighting
in the streets this is something
straight out of the road serfdom hey it
talks about how the Nazis and the
Communists fought in the streets of
Germany until the Nazis eventually won
and let's be honest with you if you
think it's going to come down to an
actual fight between the uprights and
the anti far socialists who do you think
is gonna win that it's not gonna be an T
for ya they're weak they're absolutely
weak they don't know what they're doing
I mean they've got this fantasy
conception of how they're gonna bring in
some glorious socialist revolution it's
not gonna happen right there's no
there's no strong foundation of an
ideology there is a huge deep strong
foundation and the the worst new thing
for those average people that are out
there well not only all right no for the
so for the anti farm yeah but you think
those anti fire people really I'm
talking
that are out there with the Matthews in
the bathroom you think they really have
an understanding of what politically
they have actually yeah I mean many of
them are professors like you've got an
Eric Clanton who was arrested people
probably know him as the the mask anti
file protester who hit some random chap
of the head of the bike rack that guy's
a professor you know or a lecture at a
university in and eat I mean on his like
on his dating profile he put his
interests as being revolution so dude
you are not you are revolting it's
common sense that's you know you're
revolting it's some poor kid who you
assaulted with a bike lock this isn't a
socialist revolution this is nonsense
you know it's you laughing you wish I
mean this the thing they go what we're
out on the streets doing stuff and so
yeah but the people who used to do that
actually have problems you are well a
champagne socialist you you're you're on
what fifty thousand dollars a year if
not more you know you're not yeah right
you know you know you're not even
working for the people your problem is
you hate the rich and your problem is
you've got a guilty conscience because
you're not one of the poor that's your
problem
so gun can deal with it don't go around
hitting other people because of it
honestly these people piss me off yeah
they're I mean it really it's disgusting
yeah you're doing do you don't piss me
off those when liberals say oh I'm okay
with socialism no you know if you're
okay with socialism you're not a liberal
or you don't understand socialism you
know I mean there are like non-marxist
conceptions of socialism but you won't
be able to find any of them now yeah
it's all Marxian theology allah-allah
g-suits a big theory behind it and you
you have to be opposed to that and if
you're not opposed to that you're not so
liberal you don't know what you're
talking about my guest which we're
airing tomorrow but we taped yesterday
was Peter Bogosian who you might know
who's another name he's a philosophy
professor of the Portland State
University really great guy
he doesn't have a beard no I'm thinking
of another guy who I've known him he had
quite wavy hair in a nice beard
I'm glad to be professor with a beard
you were making a pair he was he was on
your show yeah he's been on my show yeah
no there was no I'll find the name
enough well Peter called it a secular
religion which is why so here you're
calling it a theology it really it's
becoming as radicalized as a religion
yeah with with first
in all that it shares a lot of the same
properties that's why it's it's
all-encompassing it's a complete world
view and the whole world view has to be
in place for it to be working you can't
I mean like with with class with with
the liberalism it's I mean you like I
mean Hague make this point really really
clear in the what road system I'm sorry
you're thinking about Brett Weinstein I
think from Evergreen State that no no no
no that's that's a different job but hey
make this point really clear yeah you
can afford some social programs you know
that's an acceptable thing to do as long
as they universal as long as they adhere
to the principles of individualism but
you can't do that in a system that is
all encompassing and I don't say we're
totalitarian but I can't think of a
better way of describing it requires the
totality of all of your beliefs to fall
in line so this is why these people seem
like cookie cutters whereas when you go
to someone who considers themselves to
come out of this sort of English liberal
tradition they've often got very
different opinions on very on certain
subjects and aligned on the the sort of
core beliefs but these people don't you
know they they they have very and they
they said well we disagree and then okay
on what point do you disagree and this
it's some tiny fringe disagreement at
the very margins of the ideology but
most everything else is complete and
it's like it's almost a religion you
know it's so interesting you talk about
the cookie cutter mentality and we know
that they love purging people with
original thoughts and they and getting
rid of all their real individuals and
they love diversity but not diversity of
thought and even as you were saying that
I was thinking for all the videos that
I've watched of yours and for as well as
I think I know what you think I hacked
off the top of my head I don't know if
you're even pro-choice or what you think
about the death penalty exam which is
kind of interesting and you come with
probably different so I'm I'm pro-choice
but grudgingly I think it's a horrible
choice but I think all time it's a
necessary evil it's a necessary evil and
I'm against the death penalty I am as
well because it doesn't work but I think
you can make strong logical arguments
against both of them you absolutely I
mean like a counter-argument to be well
why should we have someone who has been
convicted and we can be sure of the
evidence why should we hold them at
taxpayer expense what's the point you
know what do we want to run the risk of
them actually leaving jail after
brutally murdering some children or
something I it's hard to argue against
that you know you then have to make a
sort of
moral humanist arguments say well is it
right to ever actually take a life you
know what if what if we're wrong
yeah there's always there's always got
to be that room for down there's always
got to be the room to say well you know
some tomorrow some evidence might come
up that they were actually innocent we
were completely wrong for whatever
reason and so we should we should always
keep that as an option open but I mean a
pragmatist could say yeah well it
chances are you know so isn't that the
beauty though of really caring about a
political philosophy or any philosophy
more than a party or more than a
politician or any of that in that
whatever your answer had been there I
think you could have made as strong
classical liberal or liberal arguments
as I could have made the other way we
happen to agree on both of those things
but I'm sure we can find something that
we did yeah yeah of course but I think I
think the important thing is the it's
like the platform on which to discuss it
it's not it doesn't require everyone to
agree on everything
whereas I mean this is why these sort of
like totalitarian ideologies they have
to purge the wrong thinkers because and
it's liberalism has got quite a narrow
focus as its base you know its universal
rights
you know the idea of freedom of man the
brotherhood of man all that sort of
thing the it's quite a narrow column
that most people will agree with me not
many people will turn around so you know
what I actually think we should have an
aristocracy you know I I actually think
that maybe maybe some people shouldn't
have the same rights as white people or
something like that it's it's very hard
to find someone of that and so it's easy
for most people to agree with this Court
and then branch off into various strains
whereas with the socialism is
effectively the reverse yeah you know
it's very very very demanding that you
believe all of these things because all
of these ideas prop one another up you
know you you if you take out one like
you know core piece of it then it
affects all of these other ones that
affect lis holding the whole thing
together and yeah I mean this is why
that when someone starts saying well
actually I'm not sure about this
like purge the wrong finger I mean you
see it happening with Laci green and the
social justice warriors now it's
terrifying yeah you know I mean I like
to think that if tomorrow I turn around
said you know I think I might actually
be a concern I think I might actually
think that we should live in what is
essentially a Christian controlled
society Topsy secularism
another pillar of it I mean at least I
think I would be able to have the
conversation with me I really you know
but I mean maybe maybe I'll be thrown
out of the club who knows yeah I get
thrown out of a lot of clubs for wrong
things I I like your metaphor there
because I almost see it as it's like
liberalism at its roots is sort of a
giant pot with a lot of fertile ground
and because of that you're gonna grow
out a lot of different ideas and sort of
competing ideas that hopefully hopefully
the best ones will rise to the top and
all that where progressivism is actually
a very small pot so you don't have room
to grow out a lot of computers ideas
because they got it they got to pull you
out like oh we it'll break the pot yeah
I know the pot crack when the the roots
start coming out of it and so yeah they
have to regularly weed themselves out
you know weed out the the wrong think is
the wrong growers oh yeah fit it into
the metaphor so I know we could do we
could literally do five hours of just
definitions and all of em well one thing
no on the subject of definitions there
is one important thing yeah practically
all of these ideologies think that
they're advocating for freedom that's
the that's the fundamental principle I
mean if you you can go back and read any
of the source social because a hundred
years ago all of the why there's no
difference now I suppose or all of this
or prominent intellectuals that we
generally think well off now we're
socialists they consider themselves
socialists I mean you can like Bertrand
Russell Oscar Wilde or someone like that
they wrote good socialist literature and
if you go back and read it now I mean I
mean Bertrand Russell robot called
proposed rows to freedom that the
purpose of socialism in their minds is
freedom the problem is is it relies on
it relies on their being in excess of
wealth and unfortunately social
socialism doesn't produce an excess of
wealth it's it we're not in a position
where we're going to end up with a
classless stateless society it's not
gonna happen I mean what what they think
is this might happen but it's gonna be
after self great war or it won't be
after agree well that'll actually set
the clock back what will happen is when
we've finally mechanized practically
everything in the world when man no
longer has the labor then we will have
socialism
until then it's not going to happen
because one man is making things with
the fruit of his own hands
he needs to be able to own the product
of his own labor because and this comes
back to Locke's principle of self
ownership if you don't own yourself
someone else does and this is why
private property is important and it
private property will only go away when
there's no value in owning private
property and there'll only be no value
in owning private property when there is
no scarcity and when there is no
scarcity it won't matter it just simply
won't matter no one will even think
about private property because no one
will work yeah and that's the only time
that socialism is ever gonna work and
we're nowhere near it so they should
shut up and go home so I think what
you're saying is that the Socialists
should all be about robots taken over
and don't you yeah they should yeah I
mean they probably are a scary thought
well I don't think it's not terrifying
to be honest I mean I don't see any
problem with like state ownership of the
means of production in principle the the
problem is the necessary requirement
take away private ownership from
everyone else I mean I don't mind if if
if like tomorrow the government wants to
open up a giant robotics Factory where
you could go down and you could and it
would literally just be a huge assembly
line of robots producing I mean you have
a screen you press I want a new car or
something you paid how much the car
costs and then however long it takes to
build and then you've got the car made
from the state you could well be a lot
cheaper I don't mind that that's all you
know there's nothing inherently anti
individualistic about it what wouldn't
that eliminate competition which is not
necessarily because I mean it might be
that people create things that can't be
created by this you know by this
automated process or whatever but the
fact that they then as well need to take
away your ability to own your own means
of production mm-hmm that's the problem
that's when the oppression comes in and
because eventually you end up losing the
ownership of your own labor there are no
ownership of yourself it's an
interesting concession you're make this
in and of itself you're not against this
into its work there are repercussions
it's it's one that's what comes along
with it in another soffit it doesn't
infringe my rights at all you know it's
not a problem in fact I get cheaper get
some sort of cheaper product out of it
probably so it's not necessarily a
problem but it's everything that comes
with it that I can't I just have to
object it because ultimately I think
Herrick was right when he said this will
believe didn't and you serfdom and if
you look at any communist radio
a communist but they were actually
socialist regime state socialist regimes
they I mean they would force you to work
you didn't have the option like for
example like my wife is a housewife she
doesn't have to work that wouldn't be
acceptable in a socialist regime
everyone has to work but thankfully
thanks to capitalism we don't have to
you know because I own the means of my
own production and I'm successful enough
that I can actually make my wife the
lady of leisure to look after my
children yeah that's like a good Patriot
[ __ ] pretty white supremacist
patriarchal blah blah blah but that's
actually a great segue to where I wanted
to go with this which is that so I think
we've shown for the people that don't
know you you have a few of a command of
the issues you know you know I do you
know what you're talking about yeah
what's interesting is so you're in this
YouTube community that I'm obviously in
as well and you meant we just talked
briefly before we sat down but you
mention something interesting about how
it's like for us that for those of us
that have been talking about this stuff
whether you agree with this or not but
those of us that have been talking about
politics on YouTube in our sort of
circles that we're doing it they're
constantly expanding and changing all
that yeah that we're refining our ideas
oh and I love this concept because it
seems to me that internet culture is
bubbling out now into the news dream
culture and now there's this group of
people online that I think we're a part
of that have helped refine some ideas so
that people that are not part of it can
take those ideas and hopefully run for
office or put those or or just put them
into their own lives however they do
absolutely I mean like can I want to
give full credit to all of the people in
all of the ideological spheres that I
opposed there no posed to me yeah they
are absolutely intellectual
prizefighters they are 100% oh I mean I
don't want to say experts cuz a bit too
far but they are very very well versed
in their ideological sphere you know the
libertarians the socialists the
anarchists all of these people are and
the in the alt-right many of them are
really well-read in their particular
narrow genre and they are very
comprehensively read sometimes and they
put put forward their arguments very
very well and it is like a brawl down on
the down the shop floor is aware yeah
and if it wasn't for them
and if we make each other sharper
there's no doubt about it and so there's
definitely definitely a lot to be said
for the grand argument that's going on
on YouTube but yeah the there's um
there's a term called the the long march
through the institution's that the olds
rights will tell you the Marxists have
done for the universities and it's hard
to really argue with this I mean whether
it was a coordinated thing on autopsy oh
wait but it's hard to argue they've done
this because they literally are almost
in command of these universities what
was their Brett Weinstein was University
or evergreen state that was a yeah
they've taken over absolutely as I
mentioned as I mentioned to Tim pool
earlier it's like if this is this
ideology of this postmodern left and
left as a message aw think if it really
worked
shouldn't that university which was the
most arguably the most leftist campus in
America Brett Weinstein uh far left as
he described himself a deeply
progressive person well now no one liked
very much by the way culture that
shouldn't that place have been the most
harmonious
come on completely idea ideologically
pure wonderful the shangri-la of leffen
ISM and instead it's an intolerant
psychotic bin of lunacy and I love that
it all comes from him saying I'm not
going to let you discriminate against me
on the basis of my race unfair you know
happier has done applauded the guy for
standing up for himself cuz yeah when
you have a mob of ideologically
convicted bullies you know and these
people will commit violence I mean we've
seen it so many times they will start
the violence then to then stand up to
them in the flesh you know where they're
bearing down on him saying that I want a
dialectic and not debate that's
incredibly brave I mean honestly I don't
I mean a lot of people I can see why a
lot of people just lower their heads and
carry on with their lives because it's a
loss easier if you do but that's the
point that's the reason they win is
because of this we need people who do
not agree with them to say they don't
agree with them and this this is what
I'm saying that this is what actually
these happen as we need to begin our
long march through the institution's if
you're in University at the moment and
you're concerned with the progression of
Marxist ideologies and you're a liberal
and you want to promote these
you have to stay in the University I
know you might be thinking well I'm
doing my degree in whatever I'm gonna
get out I'm gonna make a lot of money
well that's you actually abdicating your
responsibilities in the next generation
I hate to say it it's so interesting
you're gonna have to stay there yeah
when I when I go to college campuses
they ask me that a lot I'll get at the
Q&A at the end there'll be kids that'll
go you know I see all this stuff my
professor doesn't want me to say this
gender pronoun or doesn't believe in
gender at all or just some other crazy
nonsense and they'll say but you know
what I gotta get out of here with a
degree and I always say look I don't
envy your position and I don't begrudge
you whatever you have to do in your own
personal living to graduate and
hopefully be a productive member of
society but the problem is once they get
you bowing there that hand will only get
strong I mean I think that's slightly
different to why men I mean like if
you're a student and you're doing a
degree don't be here you know get your
degree you you different sets of you
you're paying so students you okay get
your degree and and if you you can't
stand to be in there get out but if
you're concerned about the progress of
this ideology and you're thinking well
you know if you've finished like a PhD
whatever you think well I could become a
professor or I could enter the private
private market and and earn lots of
money well you've got the choice is is
earning lots of money more important to
you than the intellectual tradition
you're going to bequeath to your
students if you were to become a
professor you know and there's a lot
there's a lot of people who talk down
about people who teach and I mean
there's that you know those who do can
those who don't teach and I found that I
mean I it's sad really because it's this
incentivizes people because there's
nothing wrong with spreading good ideas
you know ideas that are genuinely not
bigoted and do not result in bigotry and
these people whose ideas do result in
bigotry have taken over the shop you've
got to do something about it and it's up
to you you know it's it that no one else
is gonna do it if it's not you who and
if not now when
yeah you know how much how much more you
gonna let this carry on if you honestly
I mean this to anyone watching if you're
in the investing you think you've got
the the the smarts to get to the top do
it stay there to write some books you
can still get rich write some books
become successful you've got to stand
your ground you know
that means taking a position and
advancing yourself against a hate mob
how much stronger do you think the ideas
that we're talking about are now than
they were three years ago even just the
phrase classical liberalism which was
ours was never thrown around in America
only two years ago now I hear it all the
time
Oh in the sphere of public debate
they're getting thrashed yeah absolutely
fresh I mean like I for example all the
universities at Museum Missouri
University then they've had to start
cutting programs there yeah the the
market is killing them off as it should
you know I can't imagine what's gonna
happen to Evergreen in the next round of
enrollments yeah but I imagine the
markets gonna take its toll on them too
and it's a state school where they have
alt first stuff they didn't even hit
from what I understand they didn't even
hit their the numbers of enrollees that
they had to last year to get oh really I
can't swear to that under no that's what
someone told me yeah but that either way
they have such chaos there right now
there's many strong arguments you could
make for cutting funding altogether give
it to the faculty the administration
didn't back the faculty and now they
have the the inmates running the this
this deference to the students is
baffling to me you know I I I mean when
I went to university I would never
imagine such a thing would happen but
that was like almost mom about 15 years
ago now so yeah computer science and I
hated it I hated every second of it I
didn't want to do it and I only did it
because I could use computers and it was
easy it was easy to me sighs but it was
tremendously boring and I dropped down
in the second year yeah cuz I hated it I
I'd never even considered doing like
philosophy or political science or
anything because I come from a hobby
my parents come from a working-class
background and they worked up the middle
class and they they were like when you
get something vocational you know and
you know computer science seemed
vocational but it was just tremendously
boring and I wish I never I wish I'd
gone something in the liberal arts be
honest it was much much more myself but
I guess it worked
we're making a little subset you're
doing a liberal arts in real life now I
am yeah i might actually um i watch and
go back to university just to get the
degree just to shut people up say you
don't have a degree in this well no i
don't yeah but you know look at the
people who do have degrees on this yeah
some of the best no no that's some of
the degrees make no sense and then they
wonder why they can't get jobs yeah
a little bit about internet culture
because yeah cuz that's the other piece
of this that I think yeah I think most
of our audiences really understand yeah
but a lot of it gets lost in the
translation when it bubbles up to
mainstream and so for me for example I I
do a bit of trolling online not not
direct rolling but I mean I fight a
little bit online when it's necessary
when this thing happened to me with
Mother Jones I went on an absolutist
yeah that's not trolling but
occasionally I'll you know fight with
this person because it's it's how you
make the conversation happen but I try
to keep it sort of within a certain
boundary of whatever you you definitely
have douve in to the troll world the
Pepe the means all of that stuff I I
have literally never seen you once tweet
something that I thought was truly
offensive or and certainly not bigoted
or any of that stuff you're you're using
the very tools they've used against us
on them in effect and I think it's
pretty great
well this this this is the great thing
about the internet the internet is
hilarious but the problem is that many
[Music]
the problem I think is pretensions
because a lots of people tend hold
especially well-educated people hold a
lot of pretensions around themselves and
I always find this baffling because like
well if you're accomplished in your
intellectual and you've achieved all of
these things why do you need to be
pretentious why do you need to suggest
that oh oh and someone has said
something I don't like and therefore I
will never talk to that person so what
if they did so what if they did
yeah it doesn't take away or or then
they retweet it to show what a victim
they are which I retweet them it's like
to mark these idiots right exactly but
this is about Yuriko yeah this this is
about Eureka and honestly I mean this
this is essentially Russo's conception
at the bourgeoisie this is about wanting
to be seen and wanting to have status
and I I hate the boy they're so
pretentious and what I find hilarious is
when they like these these bourgeois
socialists will turn around and say oh
well I'm doing it for the people for the
working class it's like you hate the
working class because they're the trolls
on Twitter you can't stand you know
don't even talk to me about doing
anything for the working class yeah do
not even pretend but one thing one thing
that the people
forgets is that it's the definition of
the term trolling because when the
internet was new when I was logging on
in a 28 K modem when I was at 16 or some
low I know I've been doing color at that
time
oh but some the whole the whole
definition of trolling it wasn't the
definition has been changed by social
just about justice activists to mean
sending someone a threat or hate or
something like that that's not trolling
that's just abuse and you shouldn't do
that because it's a wrong to do it B
it's totally unproductive and it creates
the victim narrative that they're
looking for yeah because they can use
the victim narrative as a form of
currency in order to buy sympathy from
other people and buy favors from them
whereas the person sending that will
only be ever seen as a villain don't do
it the you gain you put I mean though
you know I'd like to appeal on moral
level and say look it's wrong to do it
you know how do they feel on that but
that doesn't change people's minds so
think of it from your own personal
self-interest you don't gain anything
from doing it yeah they believe
victimhood is virtue and you're either
I'm going to virtue - silver exactly
that's precisely you are actually
setting them up to succeed and you're
setting yourself up to fail but that's
not what trolling actually is I'm it
released it wasn't in the early days of
the internet trolling someone was
basically putting out bait giving them
enough rope with which to hang
themselves yeah and I let them to get
let themselves get worked up over not
really anything you know and that was
the thing that was the trick I mean like
cam the bet the best example I can think
of actually is it happened to me today I
think was yes that tweets now but if
rolling is an art and that was always
the phrase that women trolling is an art
it's it's it's basically like
intellectual satire you know and
trolling is an art if you don't if you
don't understand that you don't stand
trolling and then someone tweeted at me
saying trolling is a art as in he left
off the any grammar now he's going to
jump on that and there's a point that's
the bait yeah you know it's not
offensive it's not insulting it's about
testing your capacity to divine the
meaning from what is being said and if
you can't draw out the meaning from it
then that person can have a laugh at
your expense because you just got it
wrong it's so interesting
thought of it so cleanly actually for as
much as I know about this but you know
my I enjoy the trolls for the most part
like the good especially the ones that
are being the actual troll that's right
there get the trolls now there's the
other group who are just the evil people
who are just writing go [ __ ] yourself
all yeah and horribly so I have no
problem at this point muting and
blocking though it's like you know
you're you're just adding nothing but
evil the preventing the spleen yeah they
didn't agree for some reason they just
want to let off some steam
yeah and okay well fine but I don't need
to read it or listen but I don't Dum
Dums me right I don't stop them from
doing it but the trolls there are times
where I'll tweet saying and someone will
turn it on me or mock something I didn't
I'm like man I wish I was Claude of that
yeah that was good and I've even when
I've done public events I've talked to
them about Pepe and Harambee and all
that and I'll be like I know you all
ever have secret accounts and I can see
it in everyone's face they are their
secret Pepe accounts and all that so I'm
sure but what Pepe is probably the best
example of this right of something that
meant nothing then anything and yet
affected the presidential election in
America well yeah I mean the great thing
about Pepe is Pepe the green frog yeah
who don't yeah yeah doesn't know the the
great thing is um it's almost like the
life cycle of the meme where it starts
with I think I I don't know I don't
describe this in accurately but it's
hard to describe it with any accuracy if
you look at the earliest ones it's all
Pepe looking sad and dejected and on the
outside of anything that's going on you
know he's and it was the sad frog meme
feels bad man and now if you look it's
all the sort of like staring at you
knowingly
with a little smile yeah it's the I
don't give a damn about your conceits
meme you know and this can be applied to
anything I mean you'll find you know
though for every Pepe I've had off hit
that you find you'll find a Pepe of a
you know a Jewish Pepe or you know and
you know whatever it's anything and it
can be applied to anything you know
which is why when do you have that ultra
rare Pepe that's made out of something
one of those it's a very
yeah because someone wanted I'm not
giving away it's just stupidity Andrea
and so unlike her name Hillary Clinton
yeah it's complaining about a green frog
meme to the entire world which was is
that the ultimate trolling of all yes
they got a Hillary Clinton to address
the same at the same time our campaign
is colluding with the DNC to destroy
Bernie yes she literally made the
peppe's and the Haram B's and legitimize
them
she legitimized them so she legitimized
the movement that she's so that she
apparently hated or was this hate
movement while at the same time
colluding to destroy the other guy yes
it's just absolutely ridiculous um you
know the the problem the problem is
entirely satirical you know everything
is it's entirely ironic it's entirely
satirical freakiest an I want to get to
forget where you met you know that's the
point it's it's not something you can
rebut you know that the point is to get
you to bite yeah and Hillary bit and the
sightly Hillary all you can do with
people when someone's mocking you all
you can do is go fair enough and ignore
it that's all you can do there is no
other saving grace you can't argue
against them you can't give them what
they want which is attention and this
again it comes back to the very earliest
days of the internet don't feed the
trolls that's the only way to beat a
troll they're looking for you to bite
and if you bite then they'll reel you in
if you ignore them they'll gun search
somewhere else for a bite do you think
it really shows how patently out of
touch she is end the campaign but she
obviously had no idea what Pepe was but
someone from the campaign you know the
focus group was like we've been thinking
about this Hillary and we need to really
put a nail in the coffin of these people
and what we're gonna do is we're going
to talk about Pepe and that she just
went up you know and then she went up
there with the prepared speech and
talked about it showed it just showed
the archaic machinery of drivel that
that these campaigns have become well I
think actually I think it's they just
don't understand the internet because I
mean they're older you know these people
are older they're that what we would
call me Trump's campaign did get it
though because they did they did things
that were much more effective in their
yeah well where else was Trump gonna get
support from I wasn't gonna get it from
the MS amazeen yeah you know but
retweeting a pepper
on the podium genius right all right
genius let's talk about kekaa Stan
because you mentioned kekaa Stan I am a
supporter of caki Stan and the cat
people I think they deserve freedom they
deserve their land I think they're good
people who have been unfairly maligned I
am a great supporter of their I know I
will raise funds I will anything that I
can do for the people of Pakistan who
I'm sure are commenting right this very
second position on this video tell me
about the the good people of Pakistan
and their desire and need and Just Cause
yes okay keka Stan to be blunt is a
parody of identity politics and this I
don't I mean anyone who's played
everything I just said that was just
from a parody I'm afraid so I if you
didn't know now I hate the world all
right but yeah it's it's a parody of
identity politics because all of all of
these groups and it's not just on the
left it's always also on the right when
the old rights are an identity movement
classical liberalism is not an identity
movement and it's hard to fight against
identity politics especially when the
premise that the left comes with is that
white people cannot have an identity and
I mean I don't want to see white
identitarian ISM rights you know I don't
like identitarian ism of any stripe you
know and I don't want to see white
people suddenly saying well because
we're white we get X because you're not
white you get Y you know like just the
reverse of the social justice words
going well because you're not White's
you get X and because you're white you
get Y I don't want that at all you know
that's that's not equality to me that's
that's in fact the antithesis that's
again creating a new form of aristocracy
so I'm completely against the idea and
it's hard to fight unless you satirize
it and suddenly if you've got an
identity called say a cactus ani who's
an oppressed [ __ ] poster on the internet
and who's always getting banned from
Twitter or you know blocked from comment
sections and this this now that's a form
of oppression and how is it not
oppression what did you do I posted a
joke well we're gonna censor you for
that joke well now I am actually being
oppressed this is I mean it's something
wrong it's a very a very mild form of
oppression is not it but it's high level
control it yeah it is high level
is very technically oppression and so
now I have a victim identity now I am a
victimized class now I deserve to buy
into all of your identity politics and
the best thing about it is that every
identitarian movement hates it yeah I
mean obviously the social justice
warriors think it's racist near Nancy
stuff right but the funny thing is when
Richard Spencer tweeted out hashtag free
keka Stan his followers went nuts
against him they're like you know oh
yeah oh yeah oh yeah they were just I
mean it's just like no no this is cancer
you can't do this
take this back delete this you have to
stop this perfect what what was the
reasoning there because his followers
understood it more than him like his
father is understood they I think they
completely understand that it undermines
identity politics because that's the
point of it yeah it's it's what do you
think he if he was sitting here with us
do you think he would admit that he's
playing identity politics oh yeah
absolutely
I think he's well aware that he's crazy
I mean I've seen like you know a short
end feeds of them where he's saying he
wants a wife identitarian movement in
order to compete with the left and I
don't want any identitarian movements
I'm tired of them I think they all need
to basically be be expunged I know I'm
sorry
you saying I'm white therefore I'm black
therefore I'm gay therefore I'm trans
therefore it's not an argument basically
I'd say but it's just not an argue so
you're saying you just want to be judged
on the things that you think and you
know it is that what you're telling me
that you don't want to be judged as a
bearded person or I believe there was a
famous racist who said her judging man
on the content of his character and not
the color of his skin and I mean that
guy's a tremendous racist it should be
should be fully fully exposed for the
races of the years but I'm afraid I do
agree with that point with that one
point everyone everyone makes one
exactly sorry all right we got about 50
minutes left before that before the Q&A
so let's just knock out some political
things kind of quickly give me your
basic feelings on Trump because I've
seen some people say well sorry guys not
he's not attacking Trump enough and I a
people criticize me you're not attacking
Trump enough as if there aren't enough
outlets to evil that's exactly my
feeling on it I mean you know I don't
really like Trump's politics and I never
have but the thing is it
must be obvious to everyone that there
is a great deal of pressure built up at
the bottom of our societies as in the
poorest the least able to actively
defend themselves in the public sphere
are being actively marginalised by the
left the left intelligentsia the
academics the the liberal elites and the
media these people have been and I'm
going to use the term and I mean it
literally oppressing the sort of you
know whites middle America like you know
the lower-class middle sort of I know
whatever you call the center of America
these days the middle yeah they flyover
state yeah there is no it's no surprise
that it's the coastal at least that are
in the blue and the the center that's in
the red and it's very much the same in
Britain I mean not with Trump op C but
with brexit it was a revolt by the
English working class against the
English of British elite class who would
just do exactly the same as they do in
American called racists how dare you
advocate for your own interests that's a
racist thing to do and they're only
doing that because their own interests
are threatened either now something if
we will bring that yet yeah exactly not
yeah yeah if we will bring over millions
of liberal journalists from other
countries our first people complaining
I'd be saying what do you mean I can't
get in I can't get a job writing at the
Guardian because they've hired a dozen
people who barely speak English from a
foreign country I'm am i we need to cut
down immigration but because they're not
being threatened by it and they're not
affected by it because they're in their
little gated community somewhere else
that they give a damn they're not saying
this salaries go down they're not seeing
themselves impoverished they don't care
it's the most selfish goddamn thing in
the world
you know you're so right I'll just give
you one quick personal example of this
yeah that a couple months ago I saw a
Ben Shapiro who you probably know got a
little a little fight with this guy
Jonathan Chait who I think is at New
York Magazine who's a big lefty and they
were fighting about small business and
chase said something like small
businesses and even a real thing it's
just what the media uses to keep you
quiet you know some some nonsensical
things and I responded to him and I
don't even follow this guy but I said I
was like that's insane cuz I have a
small lot of small business I have as I
am extremely proud of the employees that
I have who by the way I pay all of the
health insurance and all that we now
have a part-time or know that
I built a studio in a small business
that I'm very proud of so I wrote back
to him and I said I'm very proud of the
small business I've created I've created
several jobs I'm very proud of that and
he retweeted me and wrote Oh
something to the effect of oh you've
created several jobs implying that that
creating several jobs is somehow an
embarrassment or that I shouldn't allow
enough me or I'm not an authority but
the irony being if I had created a
hundred jobs he'd say I'm an evil
corporate money so what is the number
what are we talk about is 26 26 am I now
who doesn't know what he's talking about
or am I an evil corporate monolith was
just that's just the most ridiculous
thing I've heard I mean small businesses
are ideally what would be I mean that
they it would be better for us to have
more small business all small buildings
I would be up for a night I much prefer
it if I don't see corporations broken up
using government authority or anything
like that
but if somehow we end up in a future
where most people are either small
business owners or employees of small
businesses that in my opinion would be
better for everyone yeah you know so
when you say that that's partly because
of it's not only because of your
political be fluid but it's because of
your your literal existence you as you
just said you are a small businessman
you work for yourself there's a great
sense of pride there's a sense of
ownership and and the thing is something
I commissioned people to do things in
our commission arts I commissioned yeah
you know I I like running competitions
where I can offer quite a substantial
prize for a piece of art or something
you know and I like being able to you
know give back I might be able to do
things for people that involved you know
helping them progress in their career as
well you know as as a voluntary
transaction you know and I think that's
a fantastic thing and that it and what
what annoys me about all of this right
is that isn't what I would define as
empowerment you know a person it's just
literally building something with their
own you know two hands metaphorically
and putting something together like this
you know you have employees and the
closer you are to the power then the
more the power is responsive to you
that's just a general rule of power
politics and it applies to anything ever
you know which is why like a giant
corporation the the CEOs of this
corporation
not even in the same country as most of
their employees yeah and so then I'm
gonna respond to any of the employee
demands they're not gonna treat their
employees fairly they're not well I mean
there's a chance that they're not going
to and I'm not through malice either put
you through ignorance whereas you work
with your employees every day you're
very close to them you have friends with
them you like your employees you want
married to my executive producer that's
you want them to do well you know
there's there's definitely a strong
argument flat just for the betterment of
people's lives the actual life they're
living the the personal wealth the
happiness and their job I definitely
ain't small businesses a much better fun
giant soulless corporation yes and and
therein lies the rub I have Tim a few
employees here eat weeds you say no look
at this oh okay John yeah all right wait
I want to dive a little more into brexit
because we did not in America there was
not a great understanding of what was
going there was there's no yeah that's
funny I mean there was in effect we had
no coverage of it until about two days
before then the day before there was a
ton of coverage the day after everyone
was going crazy like oh my god what
happened sort of like the day after
Trump yeah and now there's no discussion
of it again but breakdown breaks it a
little bit so III understand what you
saying about the working class versus
the elites it is now also in effect led
to korban which is which is a little
bizarre yeah okay so the the quick
breakdown is the British public has
never really liked the European Union
and I put this down
my opinion is because the European Union
is heavily dominated by the Germans
financially and philosophically you know
and the British have always been very
standoffish about the European Union
because they don't like the idea and the
European Union started as an economic
community where people would cooperate
and it has slowly but surely over the
decades been coalescing into a
federalized sovereign nation-state and
it's been trying to get all of these
trappings I mean in 2011 the British
vetoed motion for them to get their own
arm and this is particularly dangerous
because they don't raise taxes from
anyone they raise taxes from the
government they collect a portion of the
taxes raised from governments and that
they don't raise them directly
themselves so they're not they're not
accountable to any of the demos in
Europe and I don't know why most of
Europe is acceptable of this but that's
continental Europe for you
the British had not happy with this and
they demand accountability from the
politicians they always have and the the
sort of English liberalism that
Britain's always projected has always
required this and so when people and and
again it comes down to the whole
philosophy behind liberalism
it's about being a peer I mean we have
no respect for our politicians Corbin's
cult of personality is a bizarre thing
to watch because I mean you know it's
very middle-class thing to watch it yeah
but for most of the working class most
just people who aren't part of that
group they don't like korben korben was
the most well known Tony Blair was the
most disliked politician in the country
then it was Jeremy Corbyn yeah and you
know this time six months ago went over
a year ago man breaks it happened
our current prime ministers reason may
she was phenomenally popular and it was
and Gen Con was my son papa so how'd you
get there then how do you get from a
principle like Bragg's it to me strikes
me as an individualistic principle we
watch the lint roll our destiny again
how do you get from that to six months
later having the collectivist ideology
of Corbin oh this kind of sweet LeMay is
it completely on May it's on six months
ma uh yeah actually it's it's really
hard not to put it on tourism a she came
out with a tremendous big bag manifesto
she refused to debate she didn't stand
for anything she didn't come out in the
public saying she didn't attack Corbin's
ideology which she should have done who
worked so easy to it I know she should
put you out there she could always put
up a picture of Corbin giving the sure
there's a hug yeah with the quote
underneath Fidel Castro was a hero of
social justice which is an actual quote
from Jeremy Corbyn I I swear to god the
man is a lunatic he is he's a softer
talat Aryan and people because he hides
it behind this facade of being softly
spoken and and oh oh but I really care
is that okay but you didn't care when
your momentum supports which is hard
left supporting the left were putting
bricks through the rebel labor MP's
windows they didn't care then you know
he is a dangerous man and nobody wants
to see it because they like a little bit
of violin
it's completely justified they've got no
problem in it because the your morality
is based by your ideological framework
if you think the evil capitalists are
oppressing the working class then you
are totally justified in violence
towards evil capitalists and anyone who
supports their regime so all of a sudden
I mean you know they become enemies of
the people and that is that that's one
thing that liberalism can't do it can't
authorize someone into a category that
is not acceptable you know it you can't
because it's a universal philosophy is
for everyone literally every single
individual regardless of opinion
regardless of status should enjoy the
same rights and a violation of any of
those rights is a problem which is why
I'm often forced to defend Donald Trump
or Richard Spencer or someone other
people who are never liked and never get
along with but I'm afraid I can't
tolerate the left treating them the way
they do it's unacceptable so my final
question for now then we're gonna jump
you know maybe we're gonna do a drink
during the Q&A you want to do a lovely
what do you drink I feel like you know
it may be like a scotch or oh my god you
know you're a brandy guy let me see what
we can do over there we got a lot of
stuff behind you but I think we can do a
little something all right so we're
gonna do the second half of this Q&A
from the audience on that but just to
wrap this up so I sense you feel you
feel optimistic about this I sense I
sense optimism well I'm not very
optimistic my brexit but I mean just the
general ideas that we're talking about
that they are starting to yeah I found I
think I think come what I think we need
is for this Center to develop its own
political identity for the center and
not not like a not to save like a weird
you know white or whatever not identity
politics but to have a conception of
itself away from the extremes of either
side because this this is the problem I
mean like you've got hard left which are
the anti-fog commies and throwing bricks
through windows and being people by
chains and then you've got the alt-right
who are the legitimate racists who want
to you know do whatever racist things
they want to do and if you're on the
right you get kind of drawn towards that
just by association if you're on the
left you get drawn to that by
association if you're in the center like
we are yeah you've got nothing whereas I
think most people are probably a lot
closer so what we need to do is find
some sort of like woke centrist meaning
where we can say you know what [ __ ] the
extremes
them they're both wrong they're both
crazy they're both dangerous they both
don't want dialogue with the other side
whereas in the sensor if your Santa left
your center right I mean I'm sure that a
lot of people watching on the internet
right now well aware the people on the
sensor left and says we're having a lot
better conversations about politics than
anyone from the extremes [ __ ] the
extremes are a tiny fringe of idiots we
need to just ignore them
they can just be safely no you're an
idiot socialist you're an idiot all
right sir not interested in your
opinions because you are frankly batty
and you require everything any you
require radical comprehensive change to
the system that nobody wants to see no
you don't do the live sit downs that
often but you know how to end an hour
that's a beautiful ending right there
all right here's what we're gonna do
we're gonna take one minute we did two
minutes a time we're gonna take one
minute I'm gonna pour Carl a drink and
then we're gonna do a QA on on super
chat and patreon 60 seconds set your
watches
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right over I turn red right we're
back I know that took a little more than
60 seconds it was it was ambitious of me
we had to we have to pour he wanted
brandy we got whiskey
we got two whiskeys here so first off to
doing something in real life yeah real
life something that is real life
definitely different to sitting in my
office comfortably I'm Allah I'm not in
my element all right well you've got
some whisky on the rocks and we're
jumping in we're doing super chat and
patreon and and here we go I have a
feeling I mean there's already a
bajillion questions here so you better
be thinking cap on $20
Carl how are you finding the us so oh
it's wonderful
yeah I was expecting I believe it was
called coma for Nia to be a lot a lot a
lot days is everyone's everyone's been
really nice really really nice you know
I mean I I was I was walking basically
you're the way you do things hair is
different the way we do things I mean UK
and I noticed that your your junctions
are terrible and poorly poorly conceived
frankly what do you want out of our
junctions or I think well I was I was up
on the other day and I pressed the
button and I noticed that everyone was
stopped there was no one moving and this
went on for longer than I thought I was
comfortable with me honest and while I
was waiting there there was a really
nice chap I don't know he was anything
he could tell I was obviously not from
the area yeah and he bases are in and I
look the thing I've they're good we
ended up walking on the same path
because they're never home you checked
me is like hey you know we did weaves
legal here and I was like oh great I'll
have to get some and he was a while you
can't you need a license but I've got
you know the electronic cigarettes thing
with was kind of a song here have a hit
that's such a nice thing you know yeah
this is just you know I don't know you
know I'm just gonna walk away I'm never
gonna see you again you're telling me
you come to our country here and smoke
weed on the street I absolutely would
you alright we're gonna spend some time
after they can be alright super jet how
do we stop the regressives is there a
solution and will the solution be final
beef rolls fortunately we can never
actually have a final solution in a
liberal system yeah and that's a good
thing mmm-hmm so I don't know why I said
unfortunately but
but yeah the the it's the long march
you've you've got to get it wherever
these people are taking over you have to
take over because I mean fundamentally
these people are institutionalist they I
mean you've seen this everywhere
everyone who's familiar with sjw's I
seen it everywhere they go they suck up
to the power because and this is
something a lot of people don't think
about when they think about social
justice think about how they define
everything it's in terms of power and
you have to think and that's always so
you have think right do I want them in
control or do I want someone responsible
in control and often that means that if
you're like me and you're some sort of
slacker and you just want I'm gonna play
video games get stoned well that's great
but you have to do it on your own time
because society needs you to step up and
actually be responsible and do something
with your life
I hate say I'm not I'm not the guy who
wants to do either but you know yeah but
but here we are it reminds me of Jason
Whitlock who I had on from Fox Sports
one couple days ago or two weeks ago or
so we're saying how these people with
hashtag resistance they think they're
resisting something but they're actually
sucking up to the real power yeah yeah
they're the ones calling the shots yeah
is there a final solution for the
radical left okay a lot of Final
Solution
on patreon I think we basically
addressed this already but what's the
fundamental difference between classical
liberalism and socialism well the
difference is on points of like policy
but the I mean really in reality I'm at
I am actually a social liberal but I I
say well a classical liberal because it
differentiates the intellectual
tradition I'm drawing on mmm-hmm you
know I'm I'm very very concerned with
differentiating liberalism from
progressivism and liberalism from
Marxism any anything I mean any
intellectual be able to obviously thug
like well of course why would you need
to do this but it's for the layman you
know the average layman doesn't really
understand the difference I think and if
you say I'm a classical liberal then you
are firmly planting your foot in the
concept of self ownership markets you
know free-market economics all that sort
of thing you're you're firmly pointing
the foot that but I'm I'm more than
happy to take like sort of Hayek's
interpretation of the acceptability of
social programs as long as they don't
violate
principles of individuality yeah which
of individualism which means as long as
they Universal that's fine you know it's
acceptable you this you know we can bear
it it's not gonna completely ruin what
we consider to be our freedom so a few
people ask me this I get this ass all
the time but we have a couple on patreon
about this
so then how would you define the
difference between classical liberalism
and libertarianism because I get that
all the team people say David right
David they go Dave you're you keep
saying classic a liberal but it sounds
like you're a libertarian yeah are you
saying some utility of the state
absolutely well not yeah it comes into
the difference between whether you think
the state is valid or not frankly I the
libertarian movement needs to figure out
whether it can accept the existence of
the state and there are a huge number of
libertarians who are basically closet
hang caps and I mean the anarchic
communists are at least more realistic
in the idea of Anarchy that when you
have an anarchy you're not going to own
anything which is true the
anarcho-capitalists are totally
delusional they are not going to own any
property if there is no government
government is there to protect your
property rights you being part of your
own property rights and libertarians
need to understand the government isn't
evil it's just being miss Merrow
mismanaged at the moment the the state
is valid it's got a definitive place and
we need it and we need to be the ones
controlling it at the moment we're not
start on what are your thoughts on takia
do you think it's relevant in Western
societies entrails and Reid well I
believe the chemtrails are turning the
frogs gay yes that is that I saw that I
think on some will be happier you know I
actually I actually looked into the the
study Alex Jones was citing he's
actually under selling it it's actually
turning on trans yeah I I swear to God I
looked into it was a thing was in
California actually where a percentage
of the frogs they were starting to
exhibit feminine behaviors on contact
with a certain kind of chemical and ten
percent of them actually went underwent
the full transition into being female
and were fertile but I have a friend as
a doctor as I like this this only
applies to frogs and it's only this
species of frog and it's it's you know
and it wasn't part of a globalist plot
its corporate malfeasance obviously
right but it there was like a grain of
truth to it and it's
so you're saying it was the evolutionary
plot not the globalist but perhaps the
first part was about takia right he mean
ice tech he is IKEA yeah I need to know
more about it
to be honest I the basic premise I don't
know I understand the premise but are
you what I meant for the for the good
people that don't know so the basic
premise being that that in Islam there
is this law rule of rent a key principle
that says you're allowed to lie to
Westerners pretty or you're allowed to
lie to the other yeah in an effort to
increase the influence of Islam see uh I
mean I'm sure that is a I mean I know
that is a thing within Islam but I'm
hesitant to embrace the ideas
specifically because it's going to turn
into a very very convenient way to
dismiss Muslims by saying well whatever
you just said is t'keyah what I think is
right what you think is wrong you're a
liar and I don't want to do that you
know that's not engaging with what
they're saying or repeating them on
their own terms I am with you on that
why do you speak down into the middle
class I'm American and I fall into the
lower middle class because I am middle
class by the way I've never been to
college and I love my job building crop
dusters why do you speak down to the
middle class okay maybe I'm missing
something
no no that's a good point right I should
distinguish between the middle class and
the bourgeoisie because there is
difference he's talking about being
financially middle-class yeah
but the bourgeoisie is something
different it's a cultural conception
originally I think was coined by
Rousseau burr is least defined really
well by Rousseau the bourgeoisie are a
gang of pretentious [ __ ] they are the
worst of people they don't even know
that they're the worst of people they
are self-centered they are absolutely
without any conception of what is
actually good and I know because they're
actually they are good people but they
don't understand their own deficiencies
because I dropped out of university and
I went straight to the bottom you know I
was it I was poor you know I mean I've
spent times in my life where I've had to
subsist on welfare otherwise I wouldn't
have lived in a house you know whenever
had food and then I've worked my way
back out of it you know slowly but sadly
but these people don't they grow up in
in
comfortable middle-class environment
they go to university they get their
degrees they go and do their jobs and
don't they're not wealthy you know they
might be struggling because their jobs
they might get a degree in something
that doesn't pay very well and so they
might find themselves doing a stint at
Starbucks so but they hold a remarkable
amount of conceit and pretensions about
themselves and if you violate these
pretensions they despise you and that's
a problem for me because I try not to
hold pretensions because if you look at
the working class and the lower classes
they don't hold any potential yes you're
not the middle class per se dramatic
tension that comes along I heard a
subset of it I'm really talking about
the bourgeoisie yeah I say middle class
specifically in this context I think is
referring to earnings nothing wrong with
someone mid learning in fact I want you
to learn more you know and I know that
you've if you've gone up from the lower
class to get to the middle class even if
you've come down you know you've been
doing this through your own hard work
and labor and good on you you should
have more in fact I hope you learn more
I hope you become a millionaire
so self-made millionaire is the dream of
any right-thinking liberal i think yeah
i will one-up you i want you to earn
more and i want the government to take
less so that would be not there you go
super chat Dave loved your show keep it
up Sargon I told mundane Matt that if
there is one nearby he should take you
out to dinner to Five Guys Burgers
there's one within about two miles from
here by the way surprise GG represent a
toast and french fry for me and did you
get kekaa Stan on the UK census list we
haven't had the census yet I think it's
20 to 20 23 I think it's the next census
alright but I tell you when that comes
around I'm gonna be making a big noise
about that and we're gonna see how many
we can get on that I will be happy to
give you a signal boost on that super
chat how can we make centrism sexy you
gave a nice little ending to our first
hour yeah is that I mean I think sanity
and just sort of logic and reason he's
starting to have an appeal well I don't
know if it's sexy but it's an appeal now
that maybe there wasn't three years ago
the problem with just saying things are
logic and reason is that there is logic
behind the extremist positions they're
just often very selective in that logic
and so it it's not just a panacea to
appeal to people because they will just
say well we're logical as well and
technically they have a logic behind
them
but I think I think um the center left
and the center right need to turn around
say hey you know what we're actually
best buddies it's just that we've been
fighting each other for so long we
mistake each other for our enemies and
we're actually not we're like rival
siblings you know they want a certain
thing we want a certain thing but at
least we can all agree on the rules of
the game yeah you know we're not going
to just sit there and slander each
other's character we're not going to try
and we're not gonna try and ruin each
other you know we can respect that we
have a difference of opinion and we can
have a proper conversation the the
extremes of each side don't they hate
you they hate anyone to the the left or
the right of them I mean you know when a
Marxist calls you a right-wing Dave
technically they're right because
anything to the right of them is a right
women they're so far to the bloody left
I've seen the meme I do they mean all
right well this one sort of dovetails on
that super chat love the new centre idea
how do we not make the same mistake of
purging centre allies for wrong think
when we jack reject the left-right
fringes so basically if we if we the
centre a little about one thing this is
welding rods there yeah yeah this is
exactly this is where the wrong thing
happens we sit here we hash out the
ideas and good ideas will naturally rise
to the top bad ideas will just naturally
sink yeah why do you still say that your
left-wing when it comes to your
liberalism is more Center than anything
I think do you think I'm Center left yes
I mean like this is why I'm a social
liberal you know I mean you know I want
universal health care I think a social
safety net is important yeah but I also
agree that Thomas Sol makes a good point
that an excessive amount of money given
creates a perverse incentive you know I
mean and this is something that happens
regularly on council estates all across
the UK yeah well you'll get young women
who think well I could go and get career
I could gain get a job that's a lot of
work I could have a few kids out of
wedlock and the government is going to
give me that the Conservative Party in
Britain has kappa 25,000 pounds the
average wage in Britain is 22,000 pounds
that's a perverse incentive
you can't incentivize people to earn
more money by doing nothing the the
average wage by doing nothing by having
kids
yeah I'm sorry it's really actually
telling them to do nothing yeah another
from patreon can you explain to a
recovering addict issed how we still get
to help people in need of social help
without the government as it seems to be
a ground we could agree on
this is a good one that's a great quick
you personally can do it this is one
thing that drives me create this is this
is what drives me crazy that the
bourgeoisie they want the things to be
done they just don't do it themselves
and hell I'm kind of that way as well
that's why I'm happy with like a welfare
state and Social Care I don't have to
worry about those things you know I mean
I could give money to think but I would
rather just not have to and that I can
construct my own personal selfish
interests so is there probably is the
problem that there's no real way to test
that because I agree I would rather
everyone's taxes be lower giving more on
e and then you decide if you want to
give to Planned Parenthood or if you
want to give more to a homeless shelter
or whatever now yes certain people are
just gonna give nothing it's just that
it is but hopefully that would be made
up by people that would fit for such
things I think from and this is just my
own moral preference so it's it's not
something I could Thorat ativ ly say you
need to do X but for certain things I
don't want to see any paid any person
sliding through the cracks on say
healthcare or housing you know I loathe
there are homeless people I mean the the
only charity I ever do is giving money
out of my wallet to own this person and
I even fury eights me when you get some
bourgeois [ __ ] comes along and says well
he's just gonna spend on drugs good let
him spend on drugs let him spend on a
drink he's homeless for Christ's sake
yeah meanwhile there are popping pills
left hypocrisy of it you know he's
having this spent on drugs get been you
know good I don't care
you know you but and then they'll give
money to some corrupt charity who give
like 5% of it to the actual people and
spend 90% of it on advertising and wages
you know and high it's a laries for
their you know corporate executives
again and these people are hypocrite and
they can shut up the lot of them alright
if you're just joining us we are doing a
super chat and patreon chat with Carl
Benjamin sargon of akkad super chat
college Republicans of FSU
was completely destroyed by the all left
by accusing the president of sexual
harassment and embezzlement why should I
stand up now and risk my future so I
don't know I don't know about the
specific incidentally you're talking
about why should you risk your future
before you finish it agree yeah and we
addressed earlier don't do that finish
it do we just keep that down I know it
you might feel like you are being
oppressed and you
are actually being oppressed by being
forced into silence but this is just use
thinking to your own best interest
you're paying for this degree
don't let them [ __ ] you yeah I think
that's actually a better answer than I
I've always kicked it back to them and
said you know it's on you
to figure out what you have to do and
I've never felt that that answer yeah
was enough but maybe being in this case
like just get your degree and then just
don't be here oh yeah but once once
you've got the degree they can't take it
away from you you know the problem is do
you see that inherent problem though
that then then the same argument could
be well you've now got a job well this
this is why then after you get your
degree or your PhD or whatever then you
need to become professor you need to
become one of the people like Brett
Weinstein who stands up you know because
when it comes to your job okay that's
fine you can get another job as a
professor somewhere else and if a bunch
of angry leftists kick you out of your
university I'm sure that you will be
able to find another job because you
become famous you know we will we will
make you famous well no you will not be
on your own but the you have to get into
the institutions you have to get hired
as a professor become part of the
institution that they are now
cannibalizing super chat great work guys
Sargon do you have ideas about how to
dress the mass mud Muslim migrations to
Western countries without violating
human rights or allowing Western
cultures to diminish this is obviously a
great question I'm sort of classical
liberals I think we've been caught in
the middle of this we don't want Muslim
people to be discriminated against now
we're trying to have an honest
discussion about the roots of ideology
and extremism you want to be fair to
immigrants and America is a nation of
immigrants etc it's the ideal absolutely
right the first thing I would recommend
is controlled immigration uncontrolled
mass immigration is dangerous not only
for your social cohesion but it's also a
form of economic warfare against the
poor for a start that's there's the
first argument I'd make but allowing
people in who hold fundamentally
incompatible beliefs I think is a
legitimate form of discrimination if you
can I mean would you if I mean for
example if the Soviet Union existed
would you not allow mass immigration
from the Soviet Union of all these
communists in
be crazy because they would just be
advocating for communism you couldn't do
that it's the same with Islam you know
if they're advocating for gender
segregation and the act of oppression of
gays and things like this you can say no
because these go against the I mean
these would be violating the rights of
the people in your society like they
violate the rights of the people in
theirs you don't have to stand for that
and that's not bigoted that's actually
standing for something true on principle
but once they're in now we're in the
position I mean I has a well I mean
obviously not wants to do anything
that's nasty
so I mean my personal I I would maybe
provide incentives financial incentives
to you know expatriate or something like
that but again it's tough and you get
you get certain brands of Islam that are
very tribalistic like the Deobandi is a
Pakistani sect of Islam very very closed
very tribalistic very anti Western and
it's going to be very very difficult to
make those people integrate and I mean I
don't know I I don't have an answer to
that necessarily beyond that and right
and a liberal tradition really wouldn't
be about forcing them to believe
something very lives are up you know I
mean the the most important thing I
think for people to engage with them
because I mean what one thing I think we
can actually do in this regard is
weaponize the Christians like you got
people like David Wood who spends his
entire YouTube channel knocking down
Islamic arguments with remarkable
consistency and skill and I mean I would
not agree with David word I'm an atheist
dobbsy and I would never agree with
David wood on almost everything about
Christianity or the very principles of
religion and why it's good might
necessary and whether God exists and
almost something but I would love to see
him
absolutely hammering these Muslim
apologists and the in of the radical
preachers and suffering and debates
because he is going to bring Muslims to
Christianity than more Muslims Chris
Hanson and they're gonna bring
Christie's to Islam and I would rather
be around Christians who didn't want to
have a literalist interpretation of
their holy book I would much rather that
yeah you know I think I think that's on
us in the most pragmatic option can't
believe I'm defending Christianity yeah
I
I know that's just the whiskey talking
all right super chat would you ever
accept and offer to host your own show
similar to hard talk by a major network
I feel now more than ever as you have
the qualifications to do so no all right
moving on
what creators influenced you before you
got into YouTube that's a good one
big fan of Forsman kind of kind of
annoying see sam harris floundering at
the edges of internet culture not
understanding it not getting the pathway
and not just that but like I saw him on
Joe Rogan show mm-hmm he was complaining
about like Mike son of [ __ ] success
and stuff like this on something you Sam
you could be like that you mean don't
worry you don't have to look you know
Lyle not necessarily like that's unfair
but like distort or misrepresent you
don't have to do that but you just have
to understand that and Sam Harris is one
of these pretentious bourgeois liberals
he I mean he literally said I'm looking
for people to get my show but no trolls
know this now that and the other and
it's like Sam just stop it just stop
with this pretentious crap get people on
who'll be an interesting conversation
just get the guest someone who will be
good for you to talk to don't if you sit
there and put barriers to entry but
frankly of just arbitrary on your part
you're going to find yourself like the
sjw's outnumbered by people all around
you that you don't understand you not
taking the time to engage with them and
that's the reason the sjw's are losing
so it's kind of sad to see like you know
the the last standing horsemen losing
losing like the the fight for the the
the platform of ideas you know
interesting because I was a big big
respect for the Forsman you know they
mean that they were all brilliant yeah
brilliance in their respective fields
excellent arguments you know Cunha I
mean I've never been religious but gave
me good arguments to use against the
religious and against you know bigotry
in general ended to things like that in
general so it's disappointing to see Sam
kind of turning his nose up about the
other people who like him most yeah but
without getting into any private
conversations that I've had with him i
I've discussed that with him a little
bit about the the trolling culture and
and that sort of things yeah it's on
something it's not it's not malicious
its light hearted and you know it just
jokes
calm down okay someone on super chat
wants me to take you to in and out
instead of five guys in and out in my
humble opinion here in Austin is much
better than the five guys so we've
actually got five guys in Britain oh you
got five guys oh good game again you're
going in and out the argument you get
from socialists is look at countries
like Sweden Norway thoughts on this so
we search this country and we've we've
sort of it yeah but I mean the funniest
thing was when Bernie Sanders said oh
look at socialist countries like Denmark
and the Danish Prime Minister's come out
say Bernie we're a free-market economy
we're not socialist yeah they're social
liberals they're what I want you know
that there's very successful because
they're social liberals their free
market economies know strong social
programs and they do have high taxes
higher than I'm comfortable in but
they're not Marxist they're not
socialist countries this is this is the
this is the eternal thing the socialist
laws tell you on your socialized
healthcare that's socialism no socialism
is an ideology that has many different
things and it overlaps with certain
other ideologies that also want similar
things that doesn't mean the same and
you don't you don't own socialized
healthcare I'm very sorry yeah and it's
also I think partly why you've framed a
lot of this between sort of the the
freedom side or the libertarian side and
the authoritarian side yeah I think this
is a great question it's for both of us
why do you guys distinguish yourselves
as classical liberals as opposed to
regular libertarians or moderate left or
moderate right no and I that identifies
with the Whigs anymore or any other dead
political parties well it will I'm sorry
the socialists have coming right over
this a hundred years getting there
humming exactly the same conversations
that we're having now I'm sorry we're
coming back
we're coming back to fix this [ __ ] okay
we have no choice yeah exactly what are
we gonna do do nothing yeah joined
political philosophies aren't gonna work
yeah of course Jordan Peterson this is
super Chad Jordan Peterson said
civilizations go from order to
corruption tomato pizza V Jordan Peele
dude I love you so much he's great yeah
great he's really yes that's interesting
so both of us who are not believers oh
it's fun yeah I mean if he wants to hold
I mean nothing is it you know I I don't
know why he holds his beliefs in
Christianity but
it doesn't bleed into the rationale for
the other beliefs he holds he's not a
rash right he's other beliefs are still
rock-solid and that even you know I
can't disprove God exists it's a choice
whether you want to believe or not you
know I mean I'm not I'm an atheist but
I'm not necessarily anti theist as long
as it's you know I'm a secularist as
long as they can remain secular I'm
happy for them to remain religious you
know because we both agree that
secularism is the important principle
when dealing with political life sorry
what was the question the question
disappeared actually maybe we go to
Jordan Peterson said civilizations go
from order to corruption to chaos what
do you think about this in relation to
our political climate I mean it's it's
kind of yeah um kind of there ya know
we're absolutely in that position now
we're getting to a point where the
existing order has become corrupt and
it's become self-serving and that's that
that's that's why that's why I wanted
Trump to win because I knew it would
bring chaos and chaos is as they
famously say a ladder new things will
arise new people will climb this ladder
and get out and bring something good
with them
bring something necessary with them they
couldn't climb the ladder if they didn't
have a solution if they didn't have a
new way a new order that people wanted
they wouldn't have anything that's what
I wouldn't get anyway I did not vote for
Donald Trump I did videos on why not to
vote from I kept saying I don't know
what is moral solderless to I had some
of my most the people who I hold in the
highest regards such as Sam on the show
to say why not to vote for him and yet
people will still attack me as some sort
of like trump supporter and it's like I
think there's fertile ground now and
there would not have been fertile ground
I'll tell you what if if I mean I I get
accused of being a trump sport and I'm
started thinking well I would hate to
have me as a supporter because my
support for Trump was Trump's an idiot
he's a buffoon but he can get the job
done and that there's a job is flipping
the table you know show you know let's
let's throw things up in the air and
we'll see where they fall and we'll
build something new out of it become the
single brexit well the brexit was
actually more on points of principle I
genuinely support brexit whereas for me
it was more anti Hillary because Hillary
was the apotheosis of all of the
corruption in the system literally I
mean what wasn't behind Hillary that you
were personally opposed do you know
goldman sachs hillary in a mainstream
media hillary other corrupt
a Saudi Arabia Hillary you know I'm not
supporting any of these things I want
all of these things to fail I have to
support the opposition
I should have videotaped my driving to
the polling station yeah where I kept
saying to David back and forth for a
half hour I have no idea what I'm gonna
do right now and then I voted Garry
Johnson and may I be judged accordingly
all right even though he's also a nice
guy but he was just not the right guy
he's a totally nice guy he's been on the
show I would love to smoke a joint and
go skiing with him but that sounds great
yeah that's never say what I want out of
my president all right there's so many
here so let's try to not get a couple
quick patreon who would be a better
president Hillary Clinton or Diane
Abbott Hillary Clinton Wow she'd be
corrupt and terrible and awful but she'd
be better she'd be more efficient and
smart so she'd brilliant don't get me
wrong she's absolutely brilliant nine
hapless incompetent Carl I've been
watching Christopher Hitchens videos
recently and he described himself as a
Marxist I know in your opinion how does
he differ from SJW Marx it's that that's
a good question it's a little in the
weeds but yeah it's a good question it's
very much like a Lenski there's
described himself as a small C communist
and I think I would have to I mean I
would have to look up why Hitchens
consider himself a Marxist but I think
it's that he ideally liked the end goals
of what social doesn't mean like well I
I recently read the soul of man under
socialism by Oscar Wilde it's a
beautiful piece very very well written
obviously and it's enjoyable it's it's
and it's Noble you know that's the thing
there is definitely no and it was same
with Bertrand Russell there's a noble
goal that they're trying to get to it's
never gonna happen they've got no that I
mean that literally he thinks I mean he
he literally contradicts himself in the
piece where he says you know what while
man is doing hard labor like you know
sweeping streets in the rain and stuff
like that he can never fully actualize
his personality because that was the
point you know everyone should be free
to be the person that they are and I
completely agree
mm-hmm and that's really really wishful
thinking isn't it because we're never
gonna mean what are we ever gonna be a
place where mankind doesn't have to
sweep the streets or you know it's gonna
be hundreds of years time when
everything's been automated yeah when
that happens brilliant
until then let's be realistic let's
stick with what works
so basically when everything gets
automated then we can reevaluate
all of these positions please yeah like
I said I mean when we don't have to when
we don't have to labor then socialism
will be possible and in fact it would be
inevitable because there'll be no value
to anything that we do because we didn't
put any effort in to make it it's all
there for us is ramen coca breakfast
food of course of course hey saga
rendezvous fans are both you just
curious answer guns in LA are you going
on Rogen uh he's not invited me have you
had any communication with my I told him
I was coming if he wants to invite me
I'm happy yeah all right let me see if I
can find a job ping him and see what we
can do
would you support the UK joining the EU
again if reformed more to the UK
democratic model yeah literally the only
way I would support the UK joining the
EU is if the UK took over the EU and
started dictating terms because the the
Germans do things differently to the
British the Germans like to have an
entire plan and structure put in place
before anything's done and they like to
be systematic methodical
well-thought-out the British don't like
that we're happy to kind of bumble along
and muddle through and well we're
confident that we can make decisions at
the time that if they're sensible and
it's a it's not that the Germans are
wrong way right or way right in that you
know and vice versa
it's just different yeah and it's not
compatible
especially not compatible with what we
consider to be freedom man if you guys
are bumbling through I really don't know
what we're doing over here it's a whole
didn't sing it's a whole thing
this is interesting one sorry gonna be
familiar with any of Iran's works and do
you have any thoughts on objectivism you
know I've actually never read anything
by on rant I like her argument that the
smallest minorities the individual yeah
because that a works in our favor
because it's definitely against
collectivism but no I thought as I'm
aware they're a bit um bit too hard line
I mean I know something of what she was
saying but now I've never I've never
looked into Rand I've never felt the
need yeah interestingly I did an event
with them with the Iranians to do last
week you know and I said to them look if
we can fully agree on free speech I can
say whatever I want when I'm up there
and we're just gonna completely agree on
the absolute need for free speech I'll
be happy to work with you
they said we'll put all anything else
and we're looking on that and I thought
that's how you build allies so I'm happy
yeah I'm sorry I can go into colleges
with them and I'm happy I can work with
anyone who can agree on certain
principles and that's one what is the
future of your channel will you branch
out to something else like the brown
Buffalo did know eventually plans to
retire maybe maybe I'll write a novel
that's crap
or maybe I make a video game in this
crap like I wanted to before I did it
yeah
Sargon I'm a longtime fan of your
channel have recently started my own
YouTube channel similar to yours and
should have given yourself a shout-out
any advice for a recent startup what was
this name
I only have the questions here No oh
sorry I'd like to giving you a shout-out
yeah any advice read read read books
read books that you can be sure are
written by experts absorb as much of the
knowledge as you can and apply it in
what you're doing and I mean I mean
literally you have to put in the hard
work you can't just sit there and I mean
I I half-assed there for about a year
and a half before I was like right camp
is gonna buckle down and act like I'm
getting a degree in this or something
and actually read the literature on you
and Gary Edwards is a youtuber and the
philosophy professor and I have lots of
thing for him because I was quoting
Aristotle's like you know what it's even
better to read in the context that
writes and I was like alright alright
get off my ass I'll do the work and it
was worth it you know it's funny I you
do have to read these things because
although I have read some ironer and I
kept using that the smallest minority
individual quote I kept attributing it
to ayaan Hirsi Ali who is really and
then finally look at me it was ran not
and not ayaan
let's see oh this is interesting
thoughts on compulsory military or civil
service from a classical liberal /
individualist perspective the the whole
like individuals perspective as long as
everyone has to do it it's not anti
individualist because that's the whole
point of individualism it doesn't leave
anyone outside of the purview of what
it's doing it applies to everyone
equally and so it's completely
individualist
I'm actually not necessarily against
compulsory military service I think that
it would probably do the bourgeoisie a
lot of good to get down in the trenches
metaphorically
unless there's war but get get down in
the barrack rooms with the working class
and get to know them because that's the
problem they don't understand these
people they don't understand the lack of
pretensions of the working class the
work lost they can't afford pretensions
you know they've got nothing to be
pretentious about yeah they've got
they've got real things to work yeah
exactly they've got real problems and
it's only from living with them that I
understand they have real problems are
not pretentious people and you can't
afford to be pretentious and and this is
why I hate the portions it's annoying
I'm a leftist but I don't think identity
politics is a core issue and would
rather focus on things like ending
austerity and ending dependency on
fossil fuels how do we take
progressivism back that's interesting
because I would argue it's too late I
don't fear isn't he taking it back I
think it's incompatible with what we
want yeah you know what what what
progressives want will also happen under
liberalism yeah you know this is the
overlapping magisteria was talked about
earlier for example like gay rights
what's the argument against gay rights
there is none it's a religious argument
therefore we have gay rights get anyone
can get married you mean if we just have
if we just have the thing rather than
who can do the thing I mean for example
abortion it men should be able to get
abortions they won't they won't a chance
patients for one day maybe they will I
mean I don't know what will happen in
two years time you know who knows well
yeah there's a social contract exactly
but some and biological sex might go
that way too but it there's no reason to
just think it's a crummy engagement
because that means at some point in the
future if for some fluke or chance a
weird exemption to the rule that some
you know a man happens to actually need
an abortion the law prevent him from
things so so why what difference in
making fits men and women in gay you
know it's it's that kind of thing if we
just focus on the thing itself what can
people do people can do X people can do
y Y put any kind of provides on that as
to some state you know I mean the only
any exception anything that is so like
financial situation but that's not
something inherent to yourself so you
know yeah yeah Dave and crawl what
happened to atheist YouTube with Jordan
Peterson causing huge waves for
Christians why haven't these YouTube
channels addressed
Jordan Peterson's views on God that's
actually well salmon him have had two
talks one was really hard to listen to
they couldn't get their ii think in
different ways right they just but the
second one they they got much closer to
it i would love to
both of them here but do you think that
atheist YouTube whatever that is defined
as has maybe missed an opportunity to
push back on his I don't feel the need
person I don't know I don't feel that
secularism is under threat i I don't
feel that Jordan Peterson's religiosity
has anything is it is it threats and my
secularism at all I don't see the need
to fight it I think the battle has been
won you know the the Christian
fundamentalists and I'm not saying peace
in this one
yeah Christian fundamentalist have lost
the argument well no we're not going
down the road we're not enforcing things
on the basis of your religion yeah when
you know I don't I don't see anyone
actively I don't see anyone like really
advancing that cause so I'm not worried
about it so in a way the Enlightenment B
the Enlightenment and liberalism in a
lotta ways beat Christianity yeah and
now if now it has a different a
different enemy so to speak yeah but
ironically I mean they share a lot of
the same values I mean Jesus was not he
wasn't a collectivist he was an
individualist he he was a Universalist
that you know there's it's it's really
the American right that caused the
problem with Christianity and it came
from this excessive moralizing and while
they lost the argument yeah well it
really came from just a way to win
elections that Karl Rove figured let's
really get in bed with the Christian
conservatives and and make this happen
with George W Bush but that's a whole
other story
Sargon what are your thoughts on George
Soros a big fan I would imagine he's a
hugely intelligent man highly educated
you don't become a billionaire without
being at least intelligent in some way
but he's if you look at he's very
well-educated and he has a plan and I
think that this plan is very detrimental
to the lowest in the societies that we
have but he considers I think he
considers people outside of our
societies to be even lower and that's
you know and socioeconomic success they
are but he his solutions are very
detrimental to our own working classes
very detrimental and I think they're
just completely wrong it he's not evil
he just has a conception of the world
where he thinks he can make it and it's
not the one I agree on fair enough the
UN you weren't kind of easy on him I
thought that was gonna be a fault airing
I wanted to be
I could I could get plenty yeah
if extremes like Corbin are on the
fringes of society why are they growing
in popularity is it because people are
angry at the current state of affairs so
I think we sort of hit that already it's
not that I mean they were on the fringe
of society and then the center got
neoliberal because I mean this thing
another thing that's important to
remember we're not near liberals yeah I
know we we don't agree that vast
corporations should be able to meddle
with government absolutely they
shouldn't they shouldn't be able to
exploit the the poor and in other
nations you know the these are these are
things that is a that and these are
problems with liberalism you know this
is something we have to be vigilant
about and the first thing as soon as if
we can get like a Liberal Party in
government the first thing we've got to
do is smash the influence of
corporations over our governments we I
mean I personally would be quite radical
about it and I would say something like
right I mean I I would be brutal with
any politician who took money from
anywhere other than the public purse
yeah I would be brutal about it we are
talking I mean the harshest punishment
we can find for anyone who takes any
corporate money is the worst
corporations are fine if they exist it's
fine they're made up of individuals who
all vote they're all they can all
individually donate to party zamana but
to have like this sort of corporate
pandering that politicians are all
bought and paid for it's the worst it's
corrupted our society - completely do
you see that as a bit of a catch-22
though because you don't want to exert
too much state influence over things or
you think that this one well is so
corrupting in a sort of holistic way
yeah it's it's too dangerous but what
I'm not educated we all influence the
corporation's themselves I want to put
rules on the politicians mm-hmm if you
take money from these sources then you
were in trouble lately
you're the corporation's can do their
thing exactly there are always gonna be
current corrupting influences and
they're always gonna be trying to
corrupt the important the legislators
themselves so it's the legislators we
have to make sure they understand they
are the bulwark against these corrupting
influences you know and the fact they're
not at the moment and it felt is okay at
the moment I mean I've never taken any
corporate money my channel in my entire
life you know the entire existence my
channel has been entirely crowd funded
through either ad revenue even views or
patreon all in individual donations or
merchandise sales you know in small
business you know that's thing the idea
of taking corporate backing
horrific to me is stands against
everything I stand for but it's not the
corporate backing in love itself is
wrong yeah it's that I wants to and I
don't say remain pure but I can't think
of a better way of expressing that I got
mileages real quick I know right but I
want to I want to maintain that I can I
can always say look there is no chance
of these factors being an influence over
me because I'm dead set against them and
I completely agree with chanc and the
the justice Democrats are completely
support either everyone worries that the
justice Democrats are gonna go suddenly
full sjw okay so what if they do so what
I figured for Less JW they're still
gonna be against money in politics
corporate money in politics that is a
noble goal and we should support it
regardless of whether we agree than not
if they were full-on Christians like you
know really just like Christian types I
would still support their efforts to try
and get corporate money out of politics
because it has to happen but we can't
get that conversation happening while
everyone's getting yeah but what about
the white people are the black people
[ __ ] the white and black people I don't
care
oh this is my identity oh that's
interesting actually it's not get out
yeah
what are Sargon and Dave's views on the
limits of free speech on the you in the
UK in light of youtuber count dank
EULA's situations I I don't know about
that one specific hashtag free Count
Dracula please there is no justification
for a man going to court over what is
just a [ __ ] post I mean he you know
there's obviously I bet you couldn't
find a single person who thought he
legitimately was promoting Nazism okay
you couldn't find one no one is no one
in the right mind is gonna stand up and
say you know this is him promoting
Nazism because he taught he at frame one
doesn't know he taught his girlfriend's
dog to zig Heil which obviously is a
joke and it was in he literally says in
the video he's doing it to piss off his
girlfriend and he's might go to jail for
that I mean that's truly unbelievable
all right super Chad hey Sargon do you
agree or have seen the 10 natural
occurring rules for the skeptic
community bile is reptile insured it's a
rule for how the skeptic community
should conduct in manner of discourse um
no but I imagine Liz's thought it
through cuz I I know Liz reptile she's a
youtuber
yeah I knew you guys should all check
her out she's honest yeah that's the
thing she's honest and reliable I
imagine they're probably fairly sensible
haven't look I've seen them there's no
equipment
why do Britons accept the absurd notion
that brexit is a negotiation brigs it
means we're out we're leaving and we
don't need your permission
fear mongering from the left it's
disgusting yeah I mean yeah they keep
going on about a soft brexit that will
keep us inside the single market the
customs union then we're not leaving the
European Union yeah I know so now to
democracy in a certain way well it
what's worse as we also don't have a say
over the European Union right so we're
staying in we're all we're doing is
ceding our own power to the European
Union is ridiculous we have to leave
them and what seemed more frustrating is
how it might end up that we'll end up
with No Deal no we will end up with a
deal because billions of pounds and
euros are at stake and none of the
people involved want to lose billions of
pounds in euros they will all come to a
deal
they'll come to a compromise it will be
fine don't worry about the
fear-mongering
all right for those just playing along
we got about 10 more minutes QA with
sargon of akkad jab back to patron can
we have a center when the centre won't
hold what would a centre ideology look
like so I think we got that mostly to
say broad liberal the very base of it is
we're not going to call each other names
that's that's what it's basically got to
be founded on we're not going to accuse
each other of being evil yeah and we can
the most we can really do is accuse each
other of being wrong and when you say oh
you're wrong Dom why am i wrong then you
have to explain yourself then a
discussion happens it's it's this is the
problem of each extreme they accuse each
other of being evil that's a useless
term do you find when you get involved
in the shitposting and all that stuff
but that in a way can be seen as getting
away from that value you know to me like
if you're really mocking the hell out of
somebody sometimes on Twitter by the way
I'm not judging for it all these
platforms are different in a way you
know yeah absolutely I'm slightly
different on Twitter than I am here so
but you ever find that that is a bit of
a sort of Shaving of the of that idea
like on Twitter you're gonna mock some
people no mockeries fine you know
mockery isn't saying someone that you're
illegitimate you know in fact you won't
you would only ever mock someone whose
views are legitimate you know you never
mock like that you know I don't I don't
make videos about like I don't know Alex
Jones so you know his fees aren't
legitimate they're crazy views you know
and so I don't need to talk about I
don't need to mock them I don't need to
in fact I enjoy Alex Jones because I've
got a crazy day
and you know I'm always like Jesus what
is he gonna say next you know there's no
need to mock it because it's funny on
the face of it you can only mark things
that are sensible you know or at least
at least have a logical foundation even
if they're completely wild wrong
have you seen Oliver Stone's interview
of Putin and what's your opinion of
Putin as the leader of Russia
I haven't Putin is a great statesman
he's a very clever man he understands
power politics and he's a Russian
nationalist his Patriot he's not a good
man and you shouldn't expect your
leaders to be good men especially if
they come from authoritarian countries
like Russia same with Assad you know
these these are not good people morally
but they are efficient people and they
do have an ethical standard they adhere
to as in the benefit of their own people
and that unfortunately comes at the
detriment of others and in that can
include some people who become a threat
to their own position in the country I
know this is going to get misinterpreted
as many say in Putin's a good man on a
moral level he's undoubtedly highly
immoral like litvenko and undoubtedly
dozens of journalists probably have
disappeared but unfortunately that's the
nature of being an autocrat it's not my
choice I don't like what acqua see
that's why I'm in favor of democracy but
you know I'm not it's just the way life
is how would you suggest opening the
mind of an inductor indoctrinated Normie
about the toxic ideology of sjw's their
hypocrisy and the outrage machine
keeping oppression relevant in a modern
Western society but what's the best way
to pin to open that door it depends on
the individual it depends what they care
about um I guess you could look at it
through political philosophy and for
example if if you're talking to a
socialist the best thing to do is hit
them economically so explain them look
show me where socialism has made people
richer because they'll never do it
they'll never tell you that socialism
will make the poor wealthy if you're not
gonna make poor wealthy what good is it
you know your problem is the poorer -
poor him they can't get anywhere well
that's not going to help them is it you
know you've got to attack them on the
axis that they're concerned about so
like and like name another political
philosophy but you've got you've got to
you've got to attack them on the things
that they put for
you have to refute rather than providing
something that's not directly
challenging them so yeah you've got to
know the person basically this is super
chat Tommy Robinson recently said that
the people will start foreign militias
to address the Islam problems Britain
how likely do you think that is I think
with some way off from militias at the
moment but we've just had our first
right-wing anti-muslim terror attack and
the guy did say you know I kill all
Muslims I've done my part so it's not I
don't think it will happen I think it
will happen and I I mean you know I
think we're way off from it yet but
eventually I mean you know we're having
terror attacks all the time yeah you
know you can't go a week without an
Islamic terror attack if you don't think
that has to mean something has to be
done about that you're insane and you're
just detached from reality and it's not
because I hate Muslims or I give a [ __ ]
it's because I'm looking at the
objective reality that people will do
something you know they're gonna do
something it's not whether I think good
or bad what do you thinks gonna happen
when I think the right wing is gonna
come and do something terrible so let's
jump in before they do that's you know
what's the problem well usually radical
hate preachers and mosques and that the
the the couple of professors from the I
think was a University College London
had basically done a study on this and
they spent eight years or something
tracking all of this then we look people
are getting read a lot radicalized from
the internet they're getting interested
in radicalization from the internet what
it takes is like a personal connection
with someone so it's when they go to the
mosque and then they speak to the right
they get in the here Isis propaganda
they go through the mosque speak to the
radical hate preacher who's saying
basically the same thing and he
effectively recruits them into a network
which is essential and each child radio
only or the Finsbury Park mosque boys
did so it's if not Nexus that we have to
hit because these are the guys preaching
hate you know and Imam to Edie made a
good point it's like he went down to his
local market in Australian got an al
Qaeda flag
so she's just Christ you know you may as
well be selling swastikas ya know it's
exactly the same thing and so yeah we
need to hit it the the preachers and the
people you know actually disseminating
this nonsense all right we're gonna go
about four more minutes with Carl right
here and then we're going to do it
rapid fire segment on patreon I mean I
am just taking full-on advantage of you
as your sense all right they're slightly
jet-lagged I'm quite Jack I've had like
five hours sleep in the last like 36 you
seem to have a serious commander the
issues for someone with a whisky and not
asleep I've been thinking about it a lot
hey Karl love your content how would you
say your political statements have
affected your personal relationships if
at all Oh nuts all of my friends I
honestly my political positions have
changed yeah I know I I decided that and
this thing I reasoned myself into my
politics you know I I mean my parents
were not really very political at all
they weren't religious and so the
concern was about interpersonal
relations and and this is this the thing
that drives me crazy is the concept of
personal honor has been completely
destroyed in the West and I don't
understand why if if you're going to
treat someone else with respect why
should you expect respect in return and
that supersedes in my opinion any
political position I I will happily have
a polite conversation with the neo-nazi
or a communist or anyone I find
despicable on an ideological level
because it's more important in my
opinion to have the polite conversation
and to be able to actually have a
dialogue you know in to show if you show
respect someone else then regardless of
what their ideology tells them to do
they will find themselves hindered doing
anything to you from their personal
respect to you that's what honor is and
so it's I think that's more important in
politics but my parents were broadly
apolitical and so I I mean I I read Das
Kapital and I felt myself getting a bit
socialist when I was like 22 or
something and then I read Nietzsche and
thus Spoke Zarathustra and I didn't know
what to make of exciting understanding
there at the time and and yeah and and
so over the years I've basically just
been thinking about it and thinking oh I
think you know like liberalism is the
best and it's the most reliable and the
safest structure for human rights we and
for what I consider to be the the
correct proper value system yeah I
couldn't agree more
all right let's try to knock out a
couple real quick if there was a
centrist party in the UK would you try
to lead it oh no I don't
politics done well someone want to have
the top five books that we would both
want them to read there relate to this I
mean on Liberty to me is the one write I
wrote serfdom and all you know yeah I
mean honestly it's it's not really
liberalism you have to read to
understand social justice that's the
thing you need to read like the prince
you need to read what's plenty olinsky's
one Oh Ruth will surround ecology so
you're you that's interesting so your
argument is read their [ __ ] basically
well no there's not that [ __ ] that's I
think power politics is an entirely
separate lens underlies everything that
everyone does but nobody understands it
read yes I read the Prince read rules
faretta calls read Robert Greene 48 laws
of power 33 for three I can't remember I
I'm a real lightweight and I'm feeling
the line yeah you're doing fine you're
doing bad but basically yeah so there's
and then read something historical I
mean Plutarch anything by Plutarch is
fantastic because that gives you he was
an ancient moralist and he beautiful
read and maybe that's just my own
personal preference but yeah I think
also just on a broad sense just knowing
some his history hmm not even political
philosophy or not just not even history
cuz when I when I was in it with the
progressives I would have conversations
with people that were public people and
we start talking history and I'd go man
you don't know basic history I'm not
just talking American history I'm
talking history of the Middle East of
Europe like just basic stuff know some
basic stuff so that your arguments have
some value what's interesting about
history is almost all of like political
history that you read is actually the
history of power politics you know what
you're reading is the interactions of
rulers and nations with each other and
that gives you the fundamental education
of what power politics is and it's
important because it's in everywhere
it's in everyone's lives they just don't
really understand it and don't really
think about it and it's it's cruel as
well that's the thing people got
understand that you can't you can't
expect into personal interactions to go
along that line and when you see someone
who is like the social justice warriors
everything they do is power politics and
they don't even realize it and they
don't even realize it but look at the
definitions
what's racism
prejudice plus plow everything sexism
prejudice plus power everything about it
is power politics I don't think they
understand it but if you understand
history you understand alinsky Robert
Greene the Machiavelli and if you're a
liberal read you know whatever you know
whatever liberal classical liberal
authors you want then you can understand
why they think what they think even if
they don't well said all right I want to
end us here on a big one but there's a
lot about centrist parties that seems to
be a big food okay you will want us to
run instead centrist candidates okay
this is a good one because I think it
encapsulates a lot of what we do do you
think that mainstream journalism will
ever recover the fact that that people
come to people like us now for news or
for opinion or I think there'll be
people at Tim Poole in future I think
he's gets a lot of support on patreon on
YouTube and with good reason because he
is an actual journalist and I I loved
seeing him on Twitter
he's about where we were like about a
year ago a few years ago yeah he's just
like Jesus Christ journalism is awful
it's just activism it's like yes dude
yes you know hey that's all it is these
days about trying to get you to believe
something rather than telling you what
happened and allowing you to make your
own decisions and draw your own
conclusions and I think it would be
people like to import but don't on it's
gonna take a long time before that
happens you know the institutions that
we have now they're powerful that built
up they've got long money they get the
stories first a lot of the time they go
through the places but you know
independent journalists like temp will
do the same and you have to support
these people and I mean I you know it
the important thing as well is like as
much as I love Lauren southern and I'd
like Lauren southern a lot you can see
how she's crossing into activism because
she's feeling morally compelled to do
something unfortunately as a journalist
you have to stand outside of that and
let's not say what she does isn't valued
yeah cuz it is but it's it's for a
political ideology rather than for the
objective collection of knowledge yeah
and I wonder you know I've had her on
the show I wonder if I said if I said to
her you know flat out do you consider
yourself an activist at all is your
journalism I think she would understand
that what she does is activist yeah II
would which also shows that the the
rules have just changed to the point
where someone that that's her that maybe
is a little more of an activist than a
journalist or both or whatever
I don't want to speak for her that
there's a space for that now it's not
because everyone's doing yes it's not
invalid yeah you know I mean there's
nothing wrong with doing activism yeah
but that I think the the real journalism
the real like the scoops will come from
people like Tim Paul who you understand
objectivity neutrality and the
presentation of information honestly is
more important than acting because when
you're doing activism a that's slightly
sliced in with journalism there will
come a time where you find yourself
skewed in favor of the activism rather
than the journalism yeah because the
journalism contradicts what you want
your activism to be right you know and
that's your bias yeah those things have
to come in carefully exactly and it yeah
you know what I love I also had love
temples work because he is just given me
the facts it gives me the information
and I will make the decision of what I
think the interpretation of that is and
that is what we need more of and I think
that eventually will be the future but
it's gonna be a long way to get there
and the the establishment that we have
now I mean that the the the Wall Street
Journal and The Times attacking YouTube
that's just the beginning they're gonna
keep going so if you're if you have a
favorite like I mean like literally you
don't need to support me III you know
might the people who back me on patreon
and buy my shares I thought I don't need
anymore supporters people at Tim Poole
the and it's not even temple temples
doing great as well it's the next
journalist who's I look I'm gonna go
some more Luke would ask you everything
these guys who are going to actually go
necks I am fat lazy it took me a long
time to come here and they you know took
a long I don't want to go anywhere I
don't do anything I'm having to talk
about what other people fun but it's
this the folks we're gonna get off their
asses and I said get to those places
support those people yeah well they're
patrons well said brother I'm glad we
did this actually in real life and and
by the way you're you ended the first
hour on on a beautiful sort of you
brought it all together very nicely you
ended this by giving a shout out to Tim
who I did two hours with today by
complete coincidence yeah I didn't I was
actually trying to work it so I didn't
have to do both on the same day so I
guess I guess there is something that
I've been happening oh yeah I think
there's something I the the woke
centrists a gang woke alright and for
the rest of you guys thanks for watching
all day four hours of this stuff I hope
you enjoyed it and I'm guessing most of
you know where to find
Carl on the YouTube but just puts our
guy is it just slash sargon of akkad
yeah oh just saw going into google and
i'm the first thing comes up I'm so
sorry historical yeah I'm so sorry all
right well thank you Carly cookies are
gone of akkad and let's get some beers
and some you know a burger but we're
gonna do it oh yeah all right thanks
everybody
[Music]